all right God for Thanksgiving a lot of
myths oh yeah its he's a trailer to the
live-action adaptation of the greatest
animation of all time so we have a
teaser trailer to the Lion King
live-action movie directed by Jon
Favreau who directed a jungle book
live-action and in the case of the
jungle book and The Lion King here by
live-action I mean also animated but
made it look live-action so I'm gonna
call it that which is funny cuz I here's
live-action Lion King I'm like I'm
interested I see this trailer I'm like
I'm interested I have thoughts but I'm
interested it's really good trailer oh
this teaser trailer really does recreate
some of the iconic shots from the movie
that's a live-action movie that this is
a trailer for which obviously it would
recreate shots from the live-action
movie I don't whatever it actually does
the recreation really well I've seen
YouTube videos showing this trailer and
running with it it's showing the scenes
that is recreating it's so great on one
hand you want to see what they do
differently in a live-action and on the
other hand I don't want them to do
anything differently look at all how do
you even say that you want perfection
altered in any way shape or form other
than translating it to live-action by
translating it I mean copying it exactly
you're watching ranking as great as it
is it's still in animation so there's
that disconnect there disconnect between
animation in the real world but if you
make it look photorealistic that's
another level of immersion just feels
more real when you're watching it which
means get ready we know what's coming
with that shot especially with the
dialogue that James Earl Jones are
saying with that shot sunset on my time
doing real James to real I'm gonna be a
mess crying that scene I crying the
scene once animated I'm gonna cry he's
not gonna be in good shape I love that
James Earl Jones is Mufasa again like I
love that I imagined that was the
easiest casting ever in the history of
castings like who we want to make a
live-action Lion King it taking place in
Africa we would like a mostly black cast
so who should we get to play Mufasa no
just do ever should it be sometimes you
just get it right the first time so just
do that again like if they didn't cast
James Earl Jones as Mufasa some casting
agent would get fired
never to cast again he could cast his
staff at whatever Baskin Robbins would
hire him after he gets fired as a
casting agent that would work and they
used the iconic Lion King music in this
trailer of course it did the same thing
for the trailer for the live-action
Aladdin which holy [ __ ] that's gonna be
a summer both pretty much what Disney
needs
it's like all they need to do is just
show teaser glimpses and give us the
music that we grew up on that we listen
to on repeat and there you go we're
gonna watch it what a cheap move smart
but cheap really smart then there's this
shot did they just show us the end of
the movie that's after everything wraps
up that's Simba roaring on Pride Rock
right let's then I don't even know why
I'm being vague like I'm not saying
that's when we fossa dies I'm not saying
that's after scar dies if you haven't
seen the Lion King by now you [ __ ]
deserve these spoilers but I'm
interested like Hans Zimmer's doing the
music for this right I believe he is at
that point is he gonna alter anything
like how do you alter the musical score
imagine you can put some different
arrangements to it imagine that's gonna
be needed because like the timestamps
not gonna be the same it's not like this
movie and the Lion King animated is
gonna be the exact runtime the events
are gonna unfold some events are gonna
take longer in the live-action movie so
I imagine the musical scores gonna need
to be adapted kind of like how Howard
Shore adapted his musical score to the
Lord of the Rings movies and he kind of
tweaked them a bit for the extended
editions I imagine is gonna be like that
maybe point is I don't want the music to
be different when the stampedes going
down do you imagine different music
playing imagine Twitter's gonna grind to
a halt ashtag not my fucked-up death
stampede music I don't know man I can't
imagine the Lion King without that
classic music witness now is before I'm
interested in this movie Jon Favreau did
great with the jungle but he has gold as
source material all I need to do is
translate it at that point I don't want
this Lion King movie be too different to
the Lion King animation I felt like
Jungle Book had that like it had the
ability to bend things certain ways
maybe I'm just speaking from a place of
bias because I so loved the Lion King
but I don't want it altered at all I
imagine people who love the Jungle Book
didn't want it altered at all so if you
were one of them I get where you're
coming from on that I'm expecting this
to be a cheap move for a cash grab which
case is basically going to be re skinned
to be photorealistic but damn it
I'm probably gonna love it if it is so
the Lion King teaser trailer that came
out a few days ago that I'm just talking
about now have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]